يعني نبداوا من تونس هيثوا نظمت قوى
واحزاب معارضه ومنظمات مدنيه مظاهرات
وتحركات احتجاجيه ضد ما تسميه تفرد الرئيس
قيس سعيد بالسلطه وتهديد الحقوق والحريات
في البلاد وانتهاك استقلال القضاء
بالتزامن مع ذكر الثانيه عشر للثوره
التونسيه التي اسقطت نظام زين العابدين بن
علي في عام 2011 وعبرت هذه القوى عن رفضها
للاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي اتخذها الرئيس
التونسي في الخامس والعشرين من يوليو من
عام 2001 2020 والمسار السياسيه الحالي
الذي يقوده وتاتي ذكرى الثوره هذا العام
في ظل الانقسام سياسيا حادا وازمه
اقتصاديه
متفاقمه تشهدها البلاد
هذا ودخل محتاجون شارع الحبيب بورقيبه في
تحدن لقرار السلطات التي حددت مسالك معينه
للمسيرات المقرره اليوم وقالت مراسله
الجزيره ان قوات الامن التونسيه بمحيطي
وزاره الداخليه منعت المتظاهرين من التقدم
في الشارع وكانت وزاره الداخليه اكدت في
بلاغ لها السبت موافقتها على عدد من طلبات
الترخيص في تنظيم المظاهرات السلميه في
شارع الحبيب بورقيبه بالعاصمه وفق مسالك
ومواقيت محدده ودعت الوزاره مختلفه الجهات
المرخص لها الى وجوب احترام المسالك
والمواقيت كما حملتها مسؤوليه تاطير
اتباعها لمنع حصول المشاحنات واعمال الشغب
وتبادل العنف بينها وفق البلاء
[موسيقى]
دعا رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه التونسيه
المعارضه احمد نجيب الشابي الى التضامن
والتكاتف من اجل رحيل الرئيس قيس سعيد
واعتبر الشابي ان خلاص البلاد لا يمكن ان
يتحقق الا برحيله
وهي رحيل قيس سعيد ارحل ارحل
[تصفيق]
وفي تصريح اذاعيا داعشاب الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الى الخروج من سقف الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو والى ان لا يبقى سجينا
بسرعه الماضي
يوم شارع الثوره يحتوي عديد الاطياف
السياسيه وفي مقدمه جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
ان شاء الله
اتحاد الشغل يخرج من سقف 25 جويليه ويلتحق
باحرار تونس الناس الماضي
المستقبل تونس تون اخوه متنوعين احرار تحت
سلطه القانون
من جهه اهدى على الامين العام للاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي
الى الاستعداد لمسمها معركه وطنيه من اجل
انقاذ تونس معلنا تنفيذ تحركات نقابيه
قطعيه في قادم الايام من اجل مطالب
اجتماعيه وخلال اجتماع النقابيا اكد
الطبوب دفاع اتحاد الشغل عن الحريات
ومناهضطه للقمع وتمسكه بحق الجميع في
التظاهر في الشارع مشيرا الى ان ما سماه
المد الشعبي غير قادر على التقدم بتونس
ولابد من خيار ثالث اضاف الطب بوبي ان
المجتمع المدني والمنظمات الوطنيه تقول
للحاكم لا للعبه بالبلاد حسب تعبيره
هذا وحضر حمل همامي الامين العام لحزب
العمال التونسي من تبعات ما وصفها بسياسه
تكريم الافواه التي ينتهجها الرئيس قيس
سعيد وخلال وقفه احتجاجيه بشارع الحبيب
بورقيبه قال الهمامي ان الشعبه التونسي لن
يرضى ابدا بعوده الديكتاتوريه من جديد
فقط
لا يمكن ان تصل الى نفسها على الشعب
معناها
بس تحكم بنفكر في التجويع وبالتفير
وبتكميم الابواغ وبالمرسوم 54 مصيره مش
يكون يا اما بالسجن يا اما الهروب من هذا
الوطن
وكان الرئيس التونسي الرئيس سعيد قد قال
ان بلاده في حاله حرب مع الفساد ومع من
وصفهم بالخونه والعملاء وخلال اجتماعه
باعضاء اللجنه الوطنيه للصلح الجزائي دعى
سعيد الى اعاده الاموال المنهوبه للشعب
ومحاسبه كل من اذنب في حق التونسيين وفق
تعبير
لا بد ان ينطلق نحن في حاله التحرك ضد
الفساد
الشعب في استرجاع الاموال المنهوبه من
الشعب وبسترجع خاصه ببعض العائدات منها
الى الشركات الاهليه